it's a much darker and more complicated
season this season but I'm excited about
stars of Outlander are spilling season 2
secrets and only ET was streaming live
to the fans from the premieres red
carpet in New York City see the eyes
look at all the Outlander fans watching
live right now oh my god that's amazing
hello there hi to everyone I hope you're
drinking a good whiskey while you're
watching I wish I was let's talk about
the future how we're going to change it
first of all we find him in Paris and
it's tough on them they've arrived in
the French my society and you know
they're kind of doing this to place to
this thing where they're trying to
change the course of history so we see
them maybe not at their most honorable
not at the most honest it starts off
very hopeful but as we know Paris is a
very poisonous place for them in their
relationship
you know Jamie is not fully healed yet
so the thing that brings them together
is actually there our Lord job and I
think those moments are really intimate
and touching before promise me that I'll
always find the way back to each other
I promise I can't let you leave here
without us talking about those sexy
scenes come on out lenders known for um
well you know there's still a couple
very much in love and there's a lot of
passion there but it's not you know it's
not the the new love it's not the
honeymoon phase anymore so it's real it
feels like a very honest relationship
you know so there's there's some
struggles but they will always they will
always have passion do you still get
butterflies when you have to film house
yeah we just get it on I mean I said
really no it's uh it's never easy you
know it's awkward but you know he's
alright he's a good mate so we have fun
we have fun we have to do